authoritarianism experts are very
concerned about Donald Trump's first
days as president and my reaction when I
read this report was you don't need to
be an expert in authoritarianism to
realize what's going on here you're
seeing the centralization of power
you're seeing authoritarian leadership
bolstered by emotional attachment by
supporters trumpets to to a tee and to
sort of accommodating or lenient party
that is open to at least not criticizing
really really despicable elements of the
political fray and then of course
authorizing or demonizing immigrants and
other countries exactly what we're
seeing under the Trump administration
Donald Trump says he wants to make
America great again by building up the
military and parading the military into
the streets again very concerning if you
understand the history of authoritarian
leadership he staged a press conference
where his press secretary just went out
and blatantly lied to the media he told
the National Park Service to stop
tweeting effectively a gag order he met
with an American intelligence agency in
what's described as an uncomfortable
meeting where he brought in his own
supporters to clap while he slammed the
media and lied about inauguration
turnout the term alternative facts
through his counselor and former
campaign manager Kellyanne Conway the
same kalyan Conway who went on NBC and
threatened Chuck Todd with cutting off
access to the presidential team if he
keeps asking questions that she doesn't
want to answer very very concerning and
authoritarian authoritarianism experts
are pointing to this combination of
actions and I think what may be most
telling is the fact that he's issuing
all these executive orders though he has
control of both houses of Congress so
it's really not about getting the most
effective legislation passed it about
power and not only is from passing
executive orders when he controls
obviously the White House the the House
and Senate are all Republican he also
criticized President Obama for use of
the mechanism known as the executive
order and then I can't forget about the
direction to the EPA charged with in by
mental protection to remove all
references to climate change in climate
data collected with taxpayer money from
the EPA website so serious concerns here
about authoritarianism yes the line
between authoritarianism and
totalitarianism is a significant there's
a large chasm chasm is a chasm chasm
chasm yeah I can't even speak correctly
written those chasm but it's chasm it's
chasm yeah because it's not Chows it's
chaos right I guess oh yeah I guess we
don't know it's obviously chaos that I
know it's bad folks it's really really
bad and you know 1984 by george orwell
back on the bestseller list it's all
happening here and academic experts on
authoritarianism are very very much
concerned I get it we are going to link
to the study that i'm referring to here